[Music]  claim the bad crab  work in a hospital  topple a dictator  save a dynasty  seek the alden ring  never let success get to your head  arrogance is failure  the quest for the elden ring will be no  different  soon it will be mine  i'm no stranger to adventure  but with towering abominations and  fearsome dragons hell bent on stopping  any would-be challenger  i'll have my work cut out for me  but i'll be ready  roaming the lands between as a tarnish  facing down warring demigods and demons  alike  stretched beyond the limits of my  resilience tested to the edge of my  imagination  i'll dance with death a hundred times if  i must  guided by grace i know i will claim my  prize and become the elden lord  but i know i'm not alone  far from it  do you two seek the elden ring  then i wish you luck  and may death  never stop you  you